all right that cold weather we
experienced throughout much of the
country this week
also froze a lot of vaccine doses from
getting delivered to all the key places
better than six
million of them were told should this be
a worry we're told right now that things
are going to get back to normal whatever
that is
and shipments of 1.3 to one and a half
million vaccines
per day per week i should say dr rashini
raj joins us right now the nyu lengo
associate professor
uh doctor it's uh good to see you again
um how big a deal
is this are any of those vaccine doses
imperiled
because of this delay what can you tell
us
morning neil great to be here well the
good news is it seems that the the doses
that were delayed weren't actually
sort of shipped down and in limbo
thawing somewhere they
they just they made the decision not to
ship them so they will be delayed but
they won't be useless they won't be
thrown out and and of course there have
been several
missteps and delays in rolling out this
vaccine it hasn't gone as smoothly as
anyone would have hoped
but people are getting vaccinated and it
is happening you know states are
kind of clamoring for more doses and for
some of those sort of hidden doses that
have been put away for second doses or
for nursing homes
it's not going as smoothly as we want
but it is going and eventually people
will
get the vaccines everyone who wants it
will get one eventually the question is
when
and of course the cost of delaying is
people getting sick and still people
unfortunately dying
you know there's been a lot of clamor
over this dr marty mccurry state but the
johns hopkins university doctors i'm
sure you're aware who said herd immunity
could be had by april
the month after next what do you think
of that yeah and i know dr mccarrion
he's a very
brilliant guy i think it's it's
difficult to say with certainty
when herd immunity is going to come and
anyone who sort of
can put their foot down and say that i'm
not sure that they have all the
information for them
it could be sooner than we think because
what he was referring to was
the many millions of people who have
been infected and maybe asymptomatic
aren't really counted in the numbers
and of course if they've been infected
that adds to the herd immunity
but we don't really know the answer to
that number we also don't know
what role the variants are going to play
so these new variants
that are more infectious and may not be
as responsive to the vaccine
that could play a role as well so when
herd immunity is coming
unclear i don't think anyone can say
with certainty i i think by the end of
the year is a good guess
much sooner than that i think it's a
little bit premature to
opine on that at this point
all right thank you dr dr rashidi raj on
that of the bite administration by the
way is saying it hopes to return to some
sort of normalcy
whatever that is by your end so we will
see